oh my god that's why I don't go out on
New Year's violence
I'm Christ thing I'm probably oh my god
all right would you like to explain yes
hello hello hello hello to all of you
out there you don't know us we are grace
and memories and my name is Margaret Cho
not related no to the other Margaret Cho
so quit sending those headshots for her
to Sonia and my name is Claire Doris
trembles like Margaret said we are
maimry and graces aunt and we'll also
librarian librarians a very respectable
job did someone tell you otherwise
there's a lot of fire behind that so I
just you know I hear things that's why
she's a good librarian yes because an
aunt could sneeze and we'd be like Shh
and I sneeze a lot and learned you two
cats oh I'm in an aunt with an insect
but please oh no we are taking over
their YouTube channels both Grace and
memory and we are installing a new
segment and smash whoa wow really
harmonized back on memories channel we
are talking about how old what should we
wait for the siren for what I think I'm
a fuss oh oh no no I gave back the gum
so we talked about how annoyed we are
with holiday work Christmas party yeah
what are we gonna rant about on your
nieces channel now you might notice the
festive accessories we have and that's
because we are celebrating New Year's we
hate going out on the actual night of
New Year Day celebrated about two weeks
before it actually have exactly the
restaurants are less fall that's drunk
people Rome industry is less overall
mayhem and we celebrate on December 16th
and with that I want to talk about New
Year's resolution oh this is a hot topic
hot topic I'm not just talking about the
store hot topic where I got these
forests have you been to next no I go to
the Avenue they have got
pasta and very inappropriate shapes ah
boobs oh I was antsy triangle legs drop
triangles inappropriate shapes position
being a triangle it should not shouldn't
be an underling one glass of Pinot
Grigio from the Cheesecake Factory oh oh
I got our topic I see some pasta and I'm
like oh that's delicious I'm having a
dinner party later tonight that night
I've got my friends all around a table
someone scoops in to get some baked ziti
bingling the babies were ding-a-lings
I don't know what I'm more offended
about that the Ziggy was a ding-a-ling
or that I was not invited to this dinner
party what was I it was 450 and over
okay all right no no some day Sunday
spotted me I'm getting crunk tonight why
Cole Diet Coke after 6 p.m. I'm crazy I
don't like to make resolutions now I'm
of the mindset that you should always be
improving yourself yeah and it doesn't
take them a Mayan calendar or whatever
the heck to tell you when to be better
don't beat you here don't meet you
heroes that is my favorite submarine
sandwich shelf down on Market Street I
don't meet you here I haven't gone is a
Panera nearby I get stuck there the soup
and the salad the pupik to Red Bull red
ball red balls Oh
they should make spoons out of something
edible red spoons red spoon a spoon shot
tank I'm dog sent for my niece you want
to see look at this thing yeah dad
that's a dog no it's not that's a dog
that's not a dog that's a dog
yes yeah and that exists you know what I
hate
meaningful me people are the West you
mean people sorry it warranted how much
Diet Coke of you head Oh
like to the Times Square ball I think it
is so crude that's the thing that
everyone's supposed to watch and talk
about a balls dropping okay if I meant
to see balls dropping I would adopt a
preteen son all right
everything is ding-a-lings yeah 2016
it's all signaling Joe many ding-a-lings
oh there's a guy named Drake he's got a
very popular song about telephones Oh
see I got in a very confusing
conversation yell at them because when
someone told me they like Drake I
thought they said they're like drapes I
talked about curtains for 20 minutes
stop
what did you say you were like oh I'm
like I like drapes yeah yeah I got a I
got my own drapes at home they probably
thought you kidnapped Drake talk about a
Seinfeld episode to something it's
almost midnight she got this a hot topic
that purchase I'm proud of this has
given me I've got a headache I'm gonna I
got verdict I got a very bad headache I
can't drive now
too many dangling I'll be should make
musical bunch of dangling Canadians if
there's one thing fedoras can hold
better than a glass of wine it's a
grudge oh oh and you don't want me
holding a grudge while holding a glass
of wine cuz that one's going in your
face well faster then car going by a
puddle and you're getting sprayed with
it in the movies be careful hydroplaning
now do you do New Year's resolution
never know you ever do someone to walk
by and see us